If you think living on Earth can be challenging,...
...try spending a day on 55 Cancri e.
The super-Earth is located about 40 light years from here...
...and at least half of it is lightly covered in blazing hot lava.
Temperatures can hover upwards of 4,400 degrees Fahrenheit.
Part of the heat problem is due to the exoplanet's incredibly close proximity to its sun.
The issue is particularly pronounced on one side of the celestial body,...
...as astronomers believe it is tidally locked to the star,...
...much like our moon is to Earth.
That means 1/2 is forever exposed, while the other remains eternally dark.
Unfortunately, that doesn't prevent the dark side...
...from having temperature issues as well.
Researchers estimate it's still a bit over 2,000 degrees Fahrenheit there.